well Madonna recently embarked on her
new Global tour called celebration and
indeed the tour is an opportunity to
celebrate her musical career which
effectively died 25 years ago and yet
has lingered on in zombified form
horrifying and confusing Spectators all
the while as far as I can tell she has
not had a number one single since the
tail end of the Clinton Administration
she hasn't been even vaguely relevant on
the music scene at any point this
Century the last time she made headlines
was when she kissed Britney Spears was
at the VMAs in
2003 way back then she had already
entered into her desperate attention
horror phase grasping for relevance in
whatever way she could and 20 years
later Britney Spears is now dancing half
naked on Instagram with butcher knives
and Madonna looks like a geriatric
Marilyn Manson still trying to be a sex
symbol even though she's been ARP
eligible for a half you know a decade
and a half and um anyway now she's on
tour now there's there's nothing wrong
with a 65-year-old singer going on tour
um artha Franklin was still performing
at the age of 75 before she died but but
a a 65-year-old woman should perform
like a 65y old woman classy refined
mature
dignified dazzling with a beautiful
vocal performance rather than relying on
sex appeal the problem though is that
Madonna can't sing and she can't write
good music and she wouldn't know
classiness and refinement if it fell out
of the sky and landed on her head which
means that the people who buy tickets
for the celebration tour and for the
life of me I can't understand why anyone
would are in for an incredibly cringy
display and however cringy you think it
might be I assure you that it's even
worse than that so case in point here's
a 12 second viral clip from Madonna's
latest uh stop on her tour and uh here's
what it looks
like
[Music]
now if you're wondering what a wreck
time at the nursing home will look like
in the year
2070 there it is and for those who are
blessed to only be listening to the
audio podcast and were therefore spared
the visuals I will just tell you that
Madonna appears to be wrapped in
aluminum foil while she clings onto a
Port Rail and gyrates clumsily to techno
music and you know it's kind of like if
you brought your elderly Aunt to a rave
and she got way more into it than you
expected it it's it's an embarrassing
sight to behold but also oddly
fascinating in the same grotesque way
that you know you might gawk at roadkill
while you drive by trying to figure out
like is that a raccoon or a fox what is
that and by the way there's a good time
to tell you that and and I did check for
myself um Madonna's next stop is in
Boston in three days and uh you might
think well it's in three days there's no
way I can go all the seats are gonna be
all the tickets are sold out no there
are plenty of seats still available in
fact you can buy a ticket for 60 bucks
you can buy a ticket for $60 to
Madonna's tour in three
days um you know people were like
literally killing each other over Taylor
Swift's tickets or buying them for
$95,000 uh but madana you can go see for
60 bucks shockingly people are not
tripping over them eles to go watch
grandma in Zumba class for two hours but
needless to say if if you find this
spectacle ridiculous then uh the problem
isn't with the Aging pop star throwing
her hip out while she's tries to twerk
on stage uh the problem is with you you
are aist according to the media the
independent reports today quote badonna
is being defended from aist trolls after
a video showing the singer performing
while holding a beam for support
serviced online earlier this week a clip
from the Like a Prayer singer
celebration tour was shared on Tik Tok
showing the star 65 dancing
energetically while holding a pole
position behind
her let's pause there for a moment um
and I can tell you it's never a good
sign when the best thing someone can say
about your dance moves is that they were
energetic like if you perform a dance
routine and you go up to someone you say
Hey what' you think and they respond
yeah wow it was uh
energetic I mean that means you sucked
okay anyway the the the independent
continues many trolls then proceeded to
incorrectly conflate Madonna's decision
to hold the rail for support with her
age and sent her messages of vital
online however it is since been revealed
that during this particular segment of
the show Madonna is dancing while
standing on a moving platform meaning
she is holding the pole for her
safety oh well that changes everything
the 65-year-old woman needed to hold the
pole while she danced for her safety
well that that solves that I guess
People magazine reports that other aging
musicians are coming to Madonna's
defense quote Chuck D is coming to
Madonna's defense on Thursday the Public
Enemy frontman 63 posted to x uh to
defend the Frozen singer 65 um by the
way Frozen singer is like I guess that's
a song that's what they mean it's not
they don't mean that she's like
literally Frozen like cryogenically
frozen although she does sort of look
like she has been uh anyway defend
against trolls making ages comments
about her performance during her career
spanning celebration tour he said quote
at 63 I know I can bike better than I
ever did and pilates ain't easy but I
give it to Madonna for pushing the bars
D said of the legendary pop star um
flavor flave is taking Pates 2o and he's
64 so agism sometimes gets like racism
both ways if you let it agism sometimes
get gets like racism both ways if you
let
it I think I think Chuck D had a stroke
when he wrote that last sentence I don't
know what that means but you see the
point is it is agism to
notice how ridiculous an older woman
looks when she tries to pretend that
she's still
22 uh and Madonna herself has made this
point many times a few months ago she
appeared at the gramys and her face if
you remember was so weird and puffy from
plastic surgery that she looked like
she'd been attacked by a swarm of bees
shortly before appearing on stage and
again people noticed how weird she
looked
and she responded by calling them aist
the guardian reported at the time quot
the 64-year-old singer denounced the
entertainment industry for its biases
biases against women who have continued
to work long into their careers quote
once again I am caught in the glare of
agism and misogyny that permeates the
world we live in a world that refuses to
celebrate women past the age of 45 and
feels the need to punish her if she
continues to be strong willed
hardworking and adventurous she said
that she has quote never apologized for
any of the creative choices I have made
nor the way that I look or dress and I'm
not going to start I've been degraded by
the media since the beginning of my
career but I understand that this is all
a test and I'm happy to do the
trailblazing so that all the women
behind me can have an easier time in the
years to
come yes thank you for trailblazing
Madonna you have blazed a trail that
other women can follow so that they too
can become addicted to Botox and end up
looking like the creepy puppet from Saw
How brave of you as we head towards a
presidential election November there's
one thing you can be sure of 2024 will
be a tumultuous year how will your
hard-earned savings fare well you're
already seeing the impacts of inflation
at the pump and the grocery store the
dollar is losing its buying power faster
than wages can increase how are you
protecting your savings consider
diversifying with gold from the Birch
gold group for decades gold has been the
choice of investors and central banks to
hedge against inflation if you have an
IRA or 401K from a previous employer
that's just Gathering dust called Birch
gold and they will help you convert it
into an IRA in Gold you won't pay a
penny out of pocket they will see simply
convert that 401k into physical gold
which unlike digital currency cannot be
tampered with text Walsh to 9898 98 and
Birch call will send you a free info kit
on gold with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
satisfied customers and the exclusive
gold company of the daily wire for the
past seven years you can trust Birch
gold to you got to text Walsh to 9998
9898 to claim your free info kit that's
Walsh to 9898 98 and secure your savings
now now as for the agism claims um let
me just say one thing we are not an
agist Society we are the opposite we are
an age denying society and and that's
how you end up with 65y old pop stars
and 80y old presidents and a congress
filled with people who took office
sometime around the war of 182 you know
it's also why plastic surgery is a
booming industry especially among gen
gen Z you know and gen Z I mean they are
actually young but in their desperation
to stay young they get lip filler and
Botox and lifts and implants and
ironically they end up looking a lot
older they end up looking like
middle-aged Stepford
Wives um agism is not even close to our
problem our problem is our refusal to
age and to accept the reality of
Aging Madonna is just she is too old to
be gyrating on stage in a skintight
aluminum leotard and we can argue about
whether anyone of any age should be
behaving that way but there's no
question that for her at her age she
looks pathetic and clumsy and
ridiculous and it's not that a 65y old
woman can't be beautiful no a 65y old
woman can be beautiful but a beautiful
65y old woman is a 65-year-old woman who
knows that she is 65 and Embraces the
fact you know Beauty and Truth go hand
inand but when you are not honest with
yourself and the world about who you are
you end up looking not beautiful but
weird and
grotesque just like there are plenty of
25-year-old women who would be beautiful
and were beautiful but then they defiled
themselves with unnecessary plastic
surgery and now they too look weird and
grotesque you know aging is a reality of
human existence and we find this reality
scary almost unspeakable really because
it reminds us of death I mean we treat
it as literally unspeakable like it's
it's embarrassing to act ask someone
their age right we we say you shouldn't
ask someone it's someone's age is an
embarrassing fact and we take that for
granted well you know in in traditional
societies you go back their
history if you went up to someone and
ask them H were they wouldn't be oh
that's I don't you know I'm I'm 25 I've
been celebrating my 25th birthday
birthday for 30 years now they wouldn't
do that they'd be proud of their age if
somebody was 75 they would say I'm 75
they'd be proud of it because it means
they've been alive for 75
years but here we treat it as actually
embarrassing to have lived a long life
it's
ridiculous and the reason is that we are
in a constant state of denial about
death you know we say things like age is
just a number but but that's only true
in the same sense that height is just a
number or the temperature outside is
just a number no we come up with numbers
to symbolize these realities but they
are still realities we could stop
keeping track of age altogether we could
assign it no number at all and that
wouldn't change the fact that we all get
older one second at a time and
eventually our our body start to break
down and our mind start to break down
and then we
die that is the lot that we have been
given happiness and Harmony and Beauty
can be found in accept it and acting
accordingly so the most beautiful thing
that Madonna could do right now is
retire and go home and put on some
slippers and sit on her porch and read
books to her grandchildren let the
wrinkles form on her face let the hair
go gray let herself be who she is and
she is not a 22-year-old pop star she
was that once she will never be that
again time to accept it and until she
does she is again cancelled if You' like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed